(quiet music)
- [Gary] You know asking
for a 1% of 1% life.
So far I've heard, I
didn't wanna eat shit and
put out stuff and deal with
no feedback for a year or two.
I don't wanna spend the three
or four hours to like learn it
'cause it seems like there's so much.
You have to realize
when you're asking to do
to live a 1% life
- yes.
that you need to do 1% things.
- Right.
(upbeat music)
- [Gary] You got your perspective.
(crowds cheering)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(mumbling)
- Um
- What's up my brother?
- It's a real pleasure.
- How you feeling?
- It's an honor man, real pleasure.
- For real, man.
- Ollie, such a pleasure.
- I like the way you talk, man.
- I appreciate that.
- You gotta way with words man.
- Yeah, man, I appreciate that.
I appreciate that.
It's a real pleasure to see you.
- We were just talking for a second
and you know I mean like,
him being like a living legend
and one of the people who could actually
touch Diddy, touch me, touch-touch
anybody at the same time.
- I'm aware of all of it.
- He has all that leverage,
he has his phone company,
and he wanted to talk a little
bit about his phone company.
- Okay, let's go.
How did it start?
Who reached out to you?
- You need to be at the right place
at the right time.
- Always.
- I'm a frequent in Miami a lot,
you know, the small community.
- Of course.
- I really wanted to get here because you-
there's a lot of you that I see that,
reminds you of myself,
which is all of this.
- Yeah?
- Because that means you spread
it so many different ways,
so how the fuck do you
real all that shit back in?
And then, make it, make it work for you?
- The reason I think I have
been able to pull it off
is sixty to eighty percent
always go to one core big thing
and then I get my nut off
on all my other stuff,
but I got one thing that's like, you know?
It's like a piece of, it's like
food, like there's always a
steak or a chicken, but
then I got a fuck-load of
Brussels sprouts and carrots,
but there's always a core.
- Hold on one sec...
- Go ahead, and that was
either the wine store,
in Springfield, Jersey, or Vayner media.
If we could figure out on
Instagram or Facebook or Snap,
Snap... there's places like,
for me, it's running ads
on the internet in lower
income individuals,
targeting lower income
individuals, who are more likely
to not have a plan in
that sweet, kinda like
twenty to thirty spot,
because if you're younger
a lot of times your parents are doin' it.
You hit them hard with a
bunch of different messages,
like "Hey, don't worry about getting plan,
we can go month to month,"
like, you catch the right video.
You catch the right...
you know, it's just like
a commercial, like on TV,
there's millions of commercials,
but "Just Do It" or "Priceless"
or "Where's the beef?".
You know like, that's the
goal of my company, always.
What's the internet version of that?
Good, cool.
Let's do that next within
the next thirty days.
Mike, let's take a photo real quick.
- We don't sleep, the money don't sleep.
Why do we have to sleep?
(hip-hop instrumental)
- So, I have put out a bunch of videos,
but very sporadically here and there,
- Yep
I get inspired every once in a while,
and I put out four or five
videos like everyone else,
- Okay.
which is why I see why most people quit.
And then, nobody watches it.
So I think back more maybe
to your wine library days
where you just kept pumping them out,
It took 5, 7, 8 years, is
that what I'm facing really?
Is that just like yeah it's
like 3-5 videos constantly...
- You're, you just care about
short term feedback loops.
- It's like, I don't
even have any feedback,
so how I'm trying to think, how do I...
- Well a couple things you could do,
you could spend money against the content.
- Okay, that I don't really have.
- Right, so then you can just be patient
and wait for it to come, and
when I say you can spend money,
and maybe you don't have this
either, but you're here, so
you should have this, I think.
Spending $200 bucks against
a video highly targeted,
will get you feedback if
that's what you're yearning.
- So your basketball
example, Lebron James vs. Me,
I do, I spend $60 or $100, I feel like
- Yep, awesome.
I am gambling at the casino.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's not a tool, so, then
it brings me back to your...
Be a practitioner, spend three
weeks and learn` and learn.
- Mhm.
When I go on youtube, especially
youtube, it just feels
like there is so much out
there, that everybody is saying
their different story, it's like hard to..
- I think the thing you have
to wrap your head around,
is what you're asking for,
think about this, you said "I.."
It's really important. I think
you know where I'm gonna go.
"I wanna live a life where I
can travel 3-4 months a year,
and still run my business and make money."
You're asking for a 1% of 1% life.
You're looking to build a personal brand,
so that you can travel 4 months a year.
- Yes.
- You have to realize, when you're asking,
to live a 1% life, that
you need to do 1% things.
- Right, right.
- So far, I didn't wanna
eat shit and put out stuff
and deal with no feedback
for a year or two,
because it doesn't feel like
its accomplishing anything.
That makes sense to me.
- No I don't wanna be, ten years
- Yeah! I don't wanna spend
3 or 4 hours to learn it,
cause it seems like there
is so much, yeah man.
- So, it's just video after
video, cause you know...
- Stick with me here then,
- Okay.
- You want to live a 1% life, like,
you have to do 1% things.
Like that's super hard.
To live a life where you get
to travel 4 months a year.
That was outrageous
what you just asked for.
I mean I'm asking for-
No, but think about
it, this is everything,
this is the whole nut, the
reason you haven't figured...
You're fucking out of your
mind with what you're asking,
thus you have to do ridiculously
hard shit to get there, and
you're not even giving
it a chance- you're not,
you're bailing on the
hardship within seconds.
Every data point that
I have heard so far and
its okay, is like no chance.
Let alone some chance.
- Right.
- Because I don't think you've
quantified how ridiculous
what you're asking for, is.
- Ok
- [Guest] Can I just say, I do that.
I am the living example. I
do exactly what you said.
- Which is?
- Travel 4 months a year
and have a business,
and have it grow, and
know the right people.
- [Guest] You're the
oldest guy on the room.
(group laughs)
- Steve, you also had three
fucking heart attacks.
(group laughs)
- [Steve] I didn't say
I do it exactly like-
- And, and, to my point, how
many years did it take us.
When did we do it, years?
Dude, I fucking worked in a
liquor store for 15 hours a day,
7 days a week for years and
somehow people put that as
like part of my narrative, but
don't give it the respect.
You wanna live a 1% life,
- I understand that, so I wanted...
- Cool so then, you wanted, you
told me you wanted to build,
you thought building a personal
brand is the way to do that.
The two core things of
building a per- which is fine.
The two core things in a personal brand,
you've bailed on immediately.
Patience and practitioner-ship,
you don't wanna do either.
I know that you no wanna take
some photos, I need to just-
- Nah nah nah, you're gonna go.
- Well okay.
- Take this to your office.
- Cool thank you. I'll see you guys later.
Thank you guys, thank you so much.
Thank you.
- We're late.
- So one thing we wanna do.
What size T-shirt are
you? I'm gonna grab you-
- Medium
- I'm gonna grab you a medium
- Am I gonna wear that?
- I'm gonna wear, I'm gonna
give you that we just wanted to
take, before we start the
programing, one quick picture
with the whole board
- Who're we missing? Simon Danny pad
- Hey man.
(crowds chatting)
How've you been? Great to see you.
- All well?
- Everything's good
- Makes me happy
(chill hip hip music)
We're here at Raise by Us
charity event and organization
that helps organizations and
their employees give back.
Really enjoying it, on the
boards, super happy about it.
Here with this beautiful man Ben Layer.
Thrillest chairman of the Group Nine.
- [Ben] Hi, CEO
- CEO not chairman?
- I don't know, actually I'm not sure
- He's a METS fan.
- What's this for? Is this just a vlog
- Yeah you're famous now
- Aw God yes
- So important people, come up and say hi.
These are all highly
supportive individuals.
My original co-founder Danny who uh,
(audience claps)
And Ariel and Beth, Emily
and Ellie in the corner.
So thank you all for uh,
so now we're gonna do
Yeah we should take the
Anyway, so we're gonna get
some of the quick panel
uh, we seem to, there we
go. David and Catherine.
- So we're gonna do this
much more quickly than
most panels but we felt
like because we have such an
esteemed group of, uh interesting
and wonderful board members
it would be disrespectful
not to let them share
their advanced knowledge
in particular Gary, Gary,
as you so Vaner media has
been in hyper growth hiring
huge numbers of people for uh, years now.
Which is shocking.
(crowd laughing)
Are you, what's the thing
that you struggle most with?
On a cultural perspective. As
you, as you sort of needed to
build a team fast, uh
how do you maintain that?
Where does it break down?
- Sure, so I think there's
a lot of variables and
I'll use the context of your
other answers in here you know.
This ecosystem a lot of
faces I see I think was was
interesting is at, when I
started Vaner I was coming from
investing, and kind of the
tech ecosystem, and with Vanor.
Things had to be profitable,
we didn't raise capital.
So, It's one thing to maintain
culture when you can get away
with losing money every year.
It's another thing when you have to
make payroll every two weeks.
So, for me I agree with everything here
and on top of it, I had
to be profitable everyday
since we've had it.
That's number one. Number two.
I didn't come from the advertising world
and so my biggest problem is,
For the nine hundred
people that work for me,
I'm a little bit of enigma
in a lot of my actions.
Because I'm also breaking the industry
and having different perspectives
on creative and media.
So the truth is, you know
everyday in the process of
what we're doing, we're,
I'm fighting a market
that doesn't necessarily
wanna buy what I'm selling.
Employees that are holding
up the past on a pedestal.
So Ben everything's a problem.
(laughter)
- Does the New York Tech Community
have an obligation or
responsibility to give back,
and why do you think that's the case?
And when does the New York Tech Community
(laughter)
- I mean, the answer
is yes, because to me,
its not about the New York Tech Community,
its about every human and
organization on earth,
if you have the-
there is a unbelievable misunderstanding
of how much abundance
there is in the world,
and I think if your lucky
enough to be in a position
to be able to, weather your
a human individual here,
or an organization of start up,
the New York Tech Community,
the San Francisco Tech Community,
the Tokyo Tech Community,
the Fashion Community in Germany,
whatever you are,
I think there's a real deep need
to understand that there's
an underlining obligation
if you've been gifted enough
with the proper D.N.A,
and circumstance that
something good is going on.
Ben, I would just wanna add one thing,
in the way that you ask
the question of like,
how do you think about the
R.O.I. of social purpose
its really interesting,
for me, I don't think about it at all.
I think one of the
things I'm fascinated by
is when your giving, that should be it.
The thought that there's so many people
that are using doing the right thing,
as a gateway drug to a financial output,
I think has caused a lot of citizesm
and a lot of things that
I've seen in startups
that make me upset, not happy,
because I've seen a
front load of the profits
to make it look like
they're trying to do good,
when there just trying to make money.
Like, when I give, I
give. Period. Move on.
And so, I think that's an
interesting conversation
that I don't see touched on,
and I think that's something
that should be debated
a little bit.
I think to that point of that interaction,
I think in these scenarios-
and I think some of us have
the luxury of being involved
on boards or being at
these kinds of events,
like, when I think about my life,
so many times I've been in the audience,
compelled by emotional stories,
or things that I could help with,
and then the high of the moment goes away.
The next day comes, life takes over,
and you don't act,
and so I think, for us, you know,
for me, weather its silent auction,
or if your in a position
where its not financial,
and you can volunteer,
I think what I'm doing
here, to wrap it up,
is like here's my action above and beyond.
And I would, it would mean the world
to all of us associated
through some hustle
as a volunteer,
bidding on something at the silent auction
that you can go flip on ebay later,
or however you roll,
or by making a donation
or getting your organization involved,
it would mean so much to us if you could
take action on today,
you know, and that's how I see it.
So thank you so much for being here.
(clapping hands)
- Thank you.
- Your welcome buddy.
(hip hop beat)